ثلاثه صواريخ بالستيه قصيره المدى كانت
التجربه الاخيره لكوريا الشماليه عام 2022
تختتم بها من اطلقت خلاله عدد غير مسبوق
من الصواريخ في سلسله اختبارات لاسلحه
شملت صواريخ عابره للقارات
التجربه سبقها ببضعه ايام اطلاق صاروخين
متوسطي المدى واختراق خمس مسيرات كوريا
للمجال الجوي لكوريا
بينما نفذت صول تجربه ناجحه على قذيفه
فضائيه تعمل بالوقود
اصداء التجربه الصاروخيه سمعت في طوكيو
غول نقلت وكاله الانباء اليابانيه ان
الصواريخ البالستيه متوسطه المدى سقطت
جميعها خارج المياه الاقتصاديه لليابان
كما اعلنت هيئه الاركان المشتركه الكوريه
الجنوبيه ان الصواريخ اطلقت باتجاه البحر
شرقي شبه الجزيره الكوريه والعالم
دبلوماسيا قالت الخارجيه اليابانيه في
بيان ان مشاورات عقدت مع واشنطن وسول اما
القياده الامريكيه في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهاادئ فقالت ان اطلاق بيونغ
الصواريخ يؤكد تاثير برنامجها الصاروخي
غير الشرعي على زعزعه الاستقرار واضافت ان
الصواريخ لا تشكل تهديدا مباشره للولايات
المتحده او لحلفاءها
عسكريا اكد مصدر في وزاره الدفاع
اليابانيه ان طوكيو تتخذوا الترتيبات
اللازمه لتطوير عده صواريخ يتراوح مداها
ما بين 2000 الى ثلاثه الاف كيلومتر وتهدف
الى نشرها عام 2030 اضافه الى صاروخ تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت بمدن يصل لنحو ثلاثه
الاف كيلومتر ويمكن بالتالي ان يصل الى اي
مكان في كوريا الشماليه وبعض اجزاء الصين
بحلول عام 2005 و30 كما كشفت اليابان هذا
الشهر عن اكبر ميزانيه عسكريه لها منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه